but this is where i get confused like
like who's right and who's wrong
it's even hard just to try to stand next
to this fire
imagine being thrown in it and paul
logan
that's the answer to your first question
but this is where i get confused like
like who's right and who's wrong are are
muslims wrong because they're muslim
are christians wrong because they're
christian and what are the consequences
of being right and wrong what is it
what's the consequence
if we get it wrong if we if we fail to
test this test
of life you'd respect me less if i
didn't tell you the truth
the truth is that abraham moses noah
all these messengers muhammad just being
the last of message
in a chain of messengers who came with
the same message to worship the one
and only creator of the heavens and
earth there's not multiple gods their
god
yes you know uh in islam
allah is is the god and judaism jesus is
the god and uh
jesus is not god he never called people
to worship him as a god as a literal son
of god
he called people to worship the one god
along without associates
and he also warned people of the
hellfire and he gave the glad tidings of
paradise eternal life in the next
paradise and so did all the other
messengers they came with that same
message not
contradictory messages one coming and
saying
worship me the other one come and
worship the son the other one won't come
saying worship the moon the other one
saying worship money no that's where
you're confused
because i'm i'm confused but
the messengers that the creator sent he
they came to bring you out of the
confusion and prophet muhammad is just
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind so the consequence again to
answer your question
and what are the consequences of being
right and wrong is the hellfire
and i hope that you respect that person
more who's giving you the truth
straightforward
because that's not that's not a true
love now the next part to answer your
question
paul logan is how do we get out of the
confusion why leave people with
a little bit of homework very simple
first i'm going to give you an analogy
and tell me if you agree with this
and then if you agree with this we can
build off that now i'm going to leave
you with something to think about
imagine a house with four doors and
in one door you were brought in and
there was statues
idols icons and then the person says
here you could take this as your
religion you can worship these stick
stones and bones and i
icons and idols and then he took you to
door number two
and then there was human beings angels
saints living things cows animals
and then the person said your second
option you can worship these things
and from those things religions are
formed and then the person took you to
door number three are you with me stay
with me almost done
paul logan door number three the person
took you in there the roof was missing
and you looked up and there was stars
and there was the moon and there was the
clouds and all these other things up
there
and the person said you can go ahead and
make a religion out of that would you
want to worship that
and the person said we got one more door
to take you through suddenly they took
you to door number four
and there the person explained to you
the attributes
of the crater of the heavens and earth
there was no stick stones idols icons
human beings
there was no stars no planets nothing
created
but the attributes of the creator
explained to you
in a beautiful verse from the verbatim
word of god almighty the quran it went
something like this
allah
say he is god the one and only the
absolute the eternal
the truly self-sufficient he begets not
nor is he begotten meaning he's not born
from anyone
nor does he have children a family a dna
no
and he's uniquely one there's nothing
comparable to him
now you go ahead if you're sincere from
that we have an innate nature inside
built inside
all of us that drive that want that
belief in the creator of the heavens and
the earth i do believe in a
creator so you decide which door would
you
pick and select if you pick number four
some sort of
unimaginable thing that made us
in this universe and everything around
us your nature hasn't been totally
corrupted
and you said yes number four then i
invite you to investigate islam and
islam simply means to submit
your will you were a christian and you
read the lord's prayer
and that lord's prayer goes a little
something like what oh our father oh god
in heaven
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy
will be done thy will be done equals
islam that's what islam is
to submit your will to the will of the
one and only
god god almighty
we say allah that's it so there's not
his god
that god their god there's only one god
so if this makes sense go ahead i invite
you
to look into islam paul logan
and remember that's the consequence the
hellfire that jesus and all the
messengers warn people out of their love
trying to save them from them giving
them salvation from the hellfire
and they invited them to the house of
peace the house
of islam they all came with they say
same message
to submit your will to the creator of
the heavens and earth not the creation
to do good deeds to be morally upright
you're going to make mistakes
but you turn to the all loving the most
forgiving and i just gave you something
to think about
tune in to the dean show paul logan
check out some of the shows that we've
had
and the homework that i leave you with
is very simple ask
your creator the creator who created you
humble yourself like jesus did and he
fell on his face and he prayed he would
he pray to himself no he prayed to the
one god and asked for guidance say the
one who created me
don't put no intermediary in the middle
no monkey in the middle
nobody in the middle between you and
your creator your maker and ask the
all-loving the most merciful the most
kind
kind the one who wants to guide you to
guide you say guide me
guide me guide me i leave you with that
paul logan
do that little thing it's a huge thing
and great things will happen
and take a little time to investigate
investigate islam
read the quran and we're here to help if
you have any questions contact us at the
dean's show watch the dean show
thank you peace be with you assalamu
alaykum